[موسيقى]
فيما يتعلق بعلاقه اداره نتنياهو واشنطن
فمن السهل القول انها متوتره ومن المثير
ان نراقب كيف ستتحول العلاقه بسبب الاحباط
الذي يعانيه المجتمع اليهودي الامريكي من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه التي تزداد
تشددا في القدس هذه العلاقه ستواجه تحديات
عديده واعتقد ان كثرا ينظرون لهذه العلاقه
على انها علاقه نفاق
[موسيقى]
بان الولايات المتحده ملزمه قانونيا
بمساعده اسرائيل في المحافظه على تفوقها
العسكري على اعدائها قد يتغير ذلك او يمكن
تعليق صفقات التسلح ان قرر اعضاء الكونجرس
التاخير فليست الاداره وحدها هي التي
توافق على الصفقات بل على العالم ان يدرك
ان اعضاء الكونجرس وخاصه الشيوخ لديهم
الصلاحيه لوقف تنفيذ الصفقات
[موسيقى]
علي ان اوضح هنا ان القلق الاميركي يكون
في معرفه ان كان سلاح الاميركي يتم
استخدامه في وضعيه خاطئه اسرائيل من
كبريات الدول المصنعه للسلاح واي سلاح
تقوم بتصنيعه مثل اي سلاح تصنعه الامارات
او اي جهه اخرى
[موسيقى]